MIHAI FLORIN IONESCU:
Can everyone hear me?
Yes, great.
Let's get started.
Well we have a
full house today.
Thank you for coming
to our session.
You guys liked the
keynote today?
Yeah, awesome stuff,
awesome HTML stuff.
Would you like to see
more cool stuff?
All right, you're at the
right session, I promise.
First let me introduce
myself and my co-presenter.
My name is Mihai
and this is Ame.
00:00:39,78 --> 00:00:39,62
AME ROOMANN-KUMIK: Hi.
MIHAI FLORIN IONESCU: And we
are developer advocates with
the Google Chrome Team.
Today we'll be talking about
developing applications with
HTML5 and about APIs available
in Google Chrome and
Google Chrome OS.
As we saw from the keynote
HTML5 has been a major
focus area over the
past year at Google.
And as you'll see again the
Google Chrome team has been
very busy implementing some
great HTML5 features.
Quick note about the
Google Wave [? side 40 ?]
session.
You can view live notes and
submit questions at this URL.
It's also displayed at the
bottom left corner of every
slide so don't worry if
you didn't write it down.
This presentation is about
HTML5 and the best way
to talk about HTML5 is
to show it in action.
As you guys probably figured
out we have built this entire
presentation as an
HTML5 application.
And because we're geeks and to
keep up with good program
practices we've even provided
you with some software metrics.
We used that many HTML elements
and JavaScript lines of
code and CSS properties to
build this presentation.
Let's have a quick look at
the agenda for the talk.
First a brief history
of web development.
Next we'll look at some of the
things we have been doing in
Google Chrome around HTML5.
We'll continue with an HTML5
primer and show you how
to use HTML5 APIs in
real case scenarios.
We have some surprise guests
and some really cool
demos, so stay tuned.
And we'll end with key
take-aways, links to
developer resources
and a Q&A session.
AME ROOMANN-KUMIK: So get your
questions in moderator now.
MIHAI FLORIN IONESCU: Right, if
you have question, shoot away.
So let's go back in time and
look at some major milestones
in web development.
It all started in 1990.
The first webpage was
created and HTML1 was born.
By 1994 the first web
browser and HTML2
appeared on the scene.
The web revolution has started.
In 1995 the revolution
continued.
Netscape took it to the next
level with the introduction
of JavaScript.
And CSS 1 shortly
followed in 1996.
Now you could write
code on the web.
We started seeing the
first web application.
1997 and 1998 brought
us HTML4 and CSS 2.
More features, more
standardization, better
browsers, better
user experience.
Still there were some serious
bottlenecks in advancing
web development on the web.
And that was the latency
of synchronous requests.
The problem was addressed
partially in 1999 with
the introduction of
XMLHTTP by Microsoft.
And in 2002 when Mozilla added
XmlHttpRequest natively
to the browser.
That set up the stage for AJAX
applications to take off.
And by 2005 we started
seeing real client
server web applications.
Think of Gmail and Google Maps.
And finally, in 2009 the
web was ready for more.
The time was right to
add more capabilities
to the web browser.
And HTML5 was introduced.
So what is HTML5?
We all know it's a W3C standard
proposal, but we like to think
of it as a generic name
for the open web.
A collection of open
web standards.
Standards such as, as
you can see-- you guys
like this animation?
Let's see it again.
So we did this with the box
to the graphics engine.
All JavaScript.
So we color-coded some
of these standards.
I know, HTML5 is really heavy.
00:05:28,758 --> 00:05:28,6
Heavy stuff.
And we randomized it so
every time is different.
Much better.
00:05:42,438 --> 00:05:42,22
Thank you.
So we color coded them.
Red for HTML.
Green for JavaScript
and yellow for CSS.
HMTL, JavaScript, CSS,
they're all part of what
we refer to as HTML5.
Let's have a quick look
at Google Chrome.
The Chrome browser is the
playground where we prototype
and implement HTML5 features.
We launched Google Chrome less
than 2 years ago with that goal
to create a browser
for the modern web.
A browser that can provide a
better user experience, better
development tools and allow
for rich web applications.
We have a few stats here
that I want to share with
you that confirm we're
on the right track.
First, we have over 70
million users and growing.
We are iterating and improving
very fast with 28 stable
releases to date.
We are improving the
performance, the end to end
performance on the browser.
The JavaScript engine
performance for example
has improved over
300% since launch.
And finally, we are focusing on
HTML5 as the underlying code of
the web that makes rich
applications possible.
The keynote emphasized that
HTML5 is the future of the web.
And I'll reemphasize that with
every HTML5 API that we launch
we make the web much
more powerful.
And that gets us one step
closer to bridging the gap
between web applications
and desktop applications.
So let's take a look at a few
APIs and a few areas where
me made great progress.
First, Canvas, WebGL, CSS 3
for rich graphics and games.
Audio and video tag for
built-in high-quality
access to multimedia.
Worker threads for native
multithreading support
and multicore CPUs.
Notification and
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
to receive alerts for a
better user experience.
Web sockets for built-in,
full duplex, real-time
messaging protocals.
And finally, application cache
and local storage for offline
access and local databases.
So all of these are
really powerful APIs.
And next we'll have a closer
look at their capabilities.
Ame will take over and show
us how we use them in
real case scenarios.
AME ROOMANN-KUMIK:
Thank you Mihai.
Just do a quick
switchover here.
So when I found out that I
would be able to give a
talk to so many people.
This is actually really
awesome that we have
so many people here.
I need to notify my boss that
my speaking fee is now double.
This is great.
Maybe I can be close
to Bristol Palin.
Maybe [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Anyway, we knew that with HTML5
we could tell you about all the
great new APIs that we really
like developers to use.
Or we could show you and
showing you all of these APIs
working together in a single
application is really awesome.
So myself and Mihai and a
couple other folks at Google
spent the last week kind
of throwing together--
or not weeks, sorry.
Last month throwing together a
HTML5 painting application.
We figured a paint app would be
a really great way to show you
kind of a lot of APIs stuffed
together and so this is kind of
like the world's premier
of an app that we're
calling Chromabrush.
And yeah, this is the
first time I've revealed
it to the public.
You can actually test
it out now if you go
00:09:57,96 --> 00:09:57,7
to chromabrush.com.
I'll just give you the caveat
that we were building it very
quickly, so we didn't have
much time to tune it
for every browser.
For the most part we display
a warning if you don't run
dev channel Google Chrome.
But please play with it.
Yes, more about that later,
but anyway I'll just
demo you a quick little
bit of functionality.
So I'm going to see if I can
actually-- hello-- kind
of replicate the famous
macintosh-- there we go--
drawing on the canvas here.
So I'll go into individual
features and how we built out
different parts of this app.
Just wanted to give you a quick
heads up of we have this app
and this is going to be a
thing we're going back to.
Naturally when we were
designing Chromabrush we kind
of broke things down into a few
areas we wanted to really focus
on, especially in the context
of this presentation.
And the first thing you would
think of when you're writing an
HTML5 paint application is
obviously the canvas element.
As I'm sure, any of you who
have any even passing
familiarity with HTML5 would
know this is the new element
that kind of let's you draw
on the browser itself.
So the API itself--
let me just reload.
That's better.
The API itself is very simple.
You can see here I'm doing
a couple lines of setup.
There's a few different methods
for doing things like drawing
shapes, primitives like
lines and circles.
And you can even get into
the pixels of an image.
And get the color value
and set it that way.
But I don't really like showing
code like this as much as I do
like just having demos
that I can click on.
So you can see here as I'm kind
of working with this, I'm just
drawing random lines
on this canvas here.
You get an idea.
I can draw lines.
I can draw circles and then I
can also get into the pixels of
the image and flip the colors.
So what I'm actually doing here
is inverting each color as I
see it in the image itself.
So I can draw a little bit more
and invert and you can see I
have pixel level control
over the image itself.
You can do other things.
You can draw images directly
onto a canvas from a source
like an image tag or a video
tag, which we'll get to later.
So the cool thing about canvas
is that even though it's in
JavaScript you can actually
draw and redraw an image so
many times that it looks very
smooth if you animate it.
If you change it
slightly each frame.
So what I do here is I'm
just redrawing this
image a bunch of times.
Very straightforward.
I'm just doing a little
spinning animation.
And I'm not actually
doing the rotation.
I basically just tell the
canvas to rotate the
image and draw it again.
There's a very cool additional
part of canvas, which is the
idea that you can get a 2D
context to draw shapes and
images and things like that.
You can also get a 3D context,
which actually let's you do
3D graphics in the browser
using an API called WebGL.
If you're familiar with open
GL, especially the variant
called OpenGL ES which is more
for like mobile applications.
You can actually realize that
the API is very similar here
and it gives you all sorts of
advanced features like writing
shaders to render
your 3D graphics.
You get things like
lighting, et cetera.
There's actually a [? Gwitz ?]
talk, I think, where they'll
be covering porting
Quake 2 to WebGL.
We think that's a really
amazing way to show you how
sophisticated WebGL can be.
My skills are basically limited
to making a box spin, but
other people are much
better than I am.
I can make good slides though.
So I'll just demo
again on Chromabrush.
Like I said, we have primitives
in the canvas, so obviously I'm
using this drawing area as a
drawing surface and I'll just
change my color a little
bit here and my line size.
You can see I'm kind of just
drawing lines and shapes.
And we also had to implement
some drawing algorithms,
which were fun to look up.
And to do things like flood
fill, so let me change
my color one more time.
You can see that I actually
went in, analyzed the pixels
on my canvas and then I
implemented a fill algorithm
that would fill continuous
regions of space with
a certain color.
So canvas kind of
let's us all do that.
We can also see, as I've been
choosing colors here, this
color picker is all rendered in
canvas, so it kind of gives you
a sense of how dynamic the
interface can be and how
nonstandard, right?
You're not limited to just
DOM elements in the page.
Even though the canvas
itself is a DOM element.
So another part that
we really wanted to
emphasize was multimedia.
There's some good
APIs for this.
Basically, audio and video.
Very straightforward, just
like canvas there are
new tags in the page.
You can see here I'm dropping a
sound clip into my page and
then I'm setting the muted
value to false in this
script here on video.
Again, it's just a simple tag.
You might notice that I'm
pointing to a WebM movie,
which is the new VPA codec.
Very cool stuff that
we announced today.
Yes, yes.
But again, I like to show
you a little bit more.
And the thing that I really get
excited about when I'm talking
about video and the web and not
using a plug-in or anything
is like it is a DOM
element in the page.
So you get access to not only
style it with CSS, but you can
actually go in and look at the
pixel data that's coming
in the video stream.
So I'll just play a little
Chrome promotional video
that we have here.
Hopefully this
won't be too loud.
So you can see.
I'm just playing a video
directly in the page.
It's unstyled right now,
but the controls are
these JavaScript buttons
that I've wired up.
Now I have my fancy button here
and what that does is just
applies CSS styles
to the video.
You can see that I've
put a border on it.
I've put a dropshadow on my
video and I've put a WebKit
reflection property
on my video.
And this is all CSS.
I didn't do anything crazy.
You know, I didn't have
to go and draw anything.
I basically put CSS styles on
it like I would any other
element in the page.
I ran out of time, so I'm
just going to play it again.
But I'm going to make
it really fancy now.
I'm going to show you what you
can do when you actually have
the power of canvas and
a videos tag itself.
So what I'm doing is I'm
actually slicing up the video
into 10 different strips and
then I'm drawing each strip
individually onto a canvas at a
different location over time.
So I'm actually animating the
dimensions of the video while
drawing the video at full frame
rate directly into the web
browser, which is all handled
natively by Chrome's
amazing rendering action.
It's really cool.
I'm looking forward to stuff
that people come up with this.
There's already demos like
exploding videos and
stuff, which are amazing.
A good artist's steal I guess.
Anyway, demos in multimedia.
So obviously we wanted a
application type of interface.
So I put in a few sound effects
when I was bored one day at
work, so hopefully we'll
get some-- there you go.
So you can hear
some side effects.
Sorry if the delay is
a little bit bad.
And I did things like-- yeah,
that's me-- when I rearranged
layers so it kinds of gives it
a nice tactile interface
to the application.
I also decided that the best
way to show people how to use
the app would be
to film a video.
Kind of just show me
clicking around.
So again, you get the idea that
these online web apps don
don't have to be static,
boring, text pages.
I mean, this is a
multi-media experience.
Has me doing a much better
hi than I did before.
That kind of thing.
So Chromabrush itself is an
image processing program.
There's some algorithms
that we have to implement.
First of all, I'm not good at
optimizations, so I had some
pretty heavy-duty CPU type
stuff, which I'm sure other
people could optimize.
But generally speaking we have
to work with a lot of data.
So we both want to store it
locally, so we don't have to
transfer it back up to the
server to do anything
interesting and we also want
to be able to process it
kind of in a way that's not
obtrusive to the end user.
You can see here that I
haven't really practiced
very much with this browser.
But what I'm doing is I'm
actually counting the number of
times that this presentations
been loaded in this browser.
And I'm doing that so I can
actually show you a new API
called local storage, which
lets you save data into the
browser per a website.
And basically, that's
persistent data that no matter
if you close the browser, if
you reload the page, that
data is always there.
It's kind of like a cookie,
but it doesn't get sent
back to the server.
So it lets client slide
applications really have data
stored locally that they can
use for settings and
things like that.
So you can see as I refresh
this application here.
Sorry, running up against
some network issues today.
OK, 4 times.
You'll notice that the fonts
are changing because one of the
fonts isn't cached very well,
so I'll just wait until
it pops up again.
So, that's not good.
That's how we store some
simple settings and things.
And then there's a few other
storage options that let you do
things like use SQL databases.
Basically, you can store
structured complex data
in the client site
and you can query it.
And we have a pretty awesome
third-party demo that
will demonstrate this.
This is going to
be really cool.
There are also a few new APIs
that we really didn't have
material for, but Indexed
DB is a standard.
Basically kind of like a SQL
database, but lets you store
data under an indexed system.
There's also an upcoming file
API, which will give each
website its own virtual kind of
file system, but you kind of
interact with files in
a file system manner.
And App Cache, which is really
cool if you want to build
an offline application.
Basically you define which
files the browser should
download in cache indefinitely
and then your application will
basically reference those
files if there's no
internet connection.
So for example, if I had put an
app cache into Chromabrush and
you were able to disconnect
from the internet than all of
the client's side files would
be there locally and
available for use.
Since there's very little
network traffic on Chromabrush
it basically downloads all the
assets and then does most
of the work client side.
That would mean it would be
almost fully functional.
I talked about processing data
and this is kind of the feature
I'm most in love
with right now.
It's basically a way for
JavaScript to not block
the UI when you're
doing complex tasks.
If you've ever had a
slow-running JavaScript webpage
you might notice that after
about 20 seconds or so the
browser kind of tells you,
hey, there's a script
running too much.
Everything's locked down.
Nothing's really rendering or
updating and that's usually
because there's like an
infinite loop or some sort of
bug in the JavaScript code.
But it can happen also if
you're doing things like some
image algorithms, which are
now possible with canvas.
So what I've implemented here
is a drawing sample were you
can see that every time I'm
moving the mouse I'm actually
getting a mouse event where I'm
drawing on the left and then on
the right I'm calculating the
difference between last
time I called this API.
Basically, the line isn't
continuous because the diff
algorithm is actually slow
enough that it blocks the
event from firing very often.
So I don't get a solid line.
Whereas now I can offload this
processing into what we call a
web worker and you can see that
the web worker line
is actually solid.
I'm kind of just
drawing around here.
And if you have an eye for
these things, on the right-hand
side the updates are
actually a lot faster, too.
So we used this as a means of
keeping the UI responsive
while doing some data
intensive tasks.
One of the ways I wanted to
demo this was actually just to
show you a simplified blur.
Talk about this while it's
calculating the background.
The blur filter in JavaScript,
my naive, not optimized
version, which runs several
passes to get a big blur.
Well, actually I'm sorry I
blurred the wrong layer.
We have layer
support by the way.
So my naive algorithm actually
allows the UI to update itself
while it's running
in the background.
If I hadn't put this into
worker thread then the UI
would be unresponsive.
I wouldn't even be able to
render a progress bar.
You can see here that the
image is slightly blurrier
then when we began.
Another very cool feature of
worker threads is that it kind
of lets us do stuff that we
wouldn't be able to normally
without putting a lot of
asynchronous kind of timeouts
and stuff into our application.
So what I did at the beginning
of Chromabrush when it was
first loaded I started up a
worker thread that sits in the
background and it kind of runs
the diff algorithm against
any change to the canvas.
And what this lets me do is
keep a persistent state in
memory of what the canvas
looked like over history.
Kind of what the changes were.
So for example, we
implemented a undo feature.
Sorry, I didn't click that.
Which actually lets me undo
the blur that I just did.
In fact, I can step back into
history a little bit more.
Now I'm currently storing this
directly in RAM, but a great
application to this would be to
write it to a SQL database or
something so that I could have
a persistent history over the
course of the user using the
application, even
across sessions.
Another kind of these focus
areas that we're talking about
is the ability to make a web
application really kind of
behave like a desktop
application.
We call this the
desktop experience.
There's a couple loosely
related features here that
we I want to talk about.
First is drag and drop.
So drag and drop isn't
new to the browser.
I mean, if you're a jQuery user
you've probably had a website
somewhere that implements
it with one line of code.
It's very, very straightforward
that way, but the trouble is
that the drag and drop events
weren't really native
events in the browser.
So there was no way that the
browser could tell you that
there's something
special going on.
Well, in HTML5 drag and drop
now, you know, kind of very
straightforward can let you
do drag and drop events
directly in the browser
as first class citizens.
The great part about this is
that the events can tell you
if there is some sort of
special situation going on.
For example, if you select
text and drag it into
another area of the page.
Or if you do something really
cool like dragging files onto
the browser itself, but
I'll show you that later.
There's also something new
that's kind of exclusive to
Chrome right now, but is coming
into the HTML5 spec and we're
hoping other browsers
adopt it pretty soon.
It's called notifications and
it's a way of a web application
kind of telling the user that
there's something interesting
going on with the app without
stealing focus or being really
too intrusive on the users
desktop experience.
So something like this would be
considered if you had Gmail,
kind of want to tell you that
there's a new message or
calendar to tell you that
you have an appointment.
I'll show you what that kind
of looks like right now.
So I'm just going to
request permission.
And now I'll show
a notification.
You can see that after this
presentation is over I'm
planning on being at the
Thirsty Bear if you want to
chat about HTML5 over a pint
because that would
be delicious.
So I'm just showing you that
the browser is minimized and
the notification's persistent.
If I were on a different tab
then that would also still
pop-up, so it's just a nice way
for the current application to
give you information
about this.
So desktop experience
in Chromabrush.
Well I thought the coolest
thing would be if I could drag
a file from my desktop directly
onto the application.
So you can see here that I
actually have a-- me again--
I actually use this
to import images.
So now I have images that are
part of the canvas because I'm
dragging and dropping them.
And I can do things
like fill them.
You know, it's part of the
canvas now, so I can actually
do stuff like that.
That's my drag and drop.
And also, we have kind of
layer support and I've also
implemented the ability
to show a notification.
So for example, remember that
slow filter that I was running
before and now I can get a
notification if the
filter is done.
So I'm going to hand things off
to Mihai for a little bit and
he's going to talk about how
you can use new properties in
CSS to make things
look really cool.
MIHAI FLORIN
IONESCU: Great job.
Yes, awesome demo.
So CSS is another area of
really exciting developments
for HTML5 applications.
With the CSS 3 spec we now
have access to some amazingly
powerful capabilities.
And I want to go with you
through a few of them.
First, everyone likes
nice visuals and
nice visual effects.
And on this slide
we'll do just that.
We built a nice application.
You all liked it.
Now we're going to build
a nice logo for it.
You want to look good.
We need a nice font, we
need some nice color, we
need some nice shadow.
Let's do it.
Can I do it with HTML5?
No Photoshop, no fancy
graphics package.
HTML5 baby.
At the top we have 5
forms to chose from.
This morning we're going to
announce that we now have
web font API and the
web font directory.
We just picked 5
fonts from there.
So you can see here I can
select the font I want.
You know, all kinds
of stuff here.
OK, lets settle on this one.
I can play with the color.
I can play with the
background color.
I can add some reflection.
I can add some shadow, some
nice-looking shadowy font.
And of course, every sleek
and cool looking logo has to
have rounded corners, right?
Rounded corners has been called
the holy grail of CSS and
before CSS 3 you had to go
through countless hacks
to achieve this effect.
Now we'll do it with
one line of code.
There we go.
So here we go.
Our nice Chromabrush logo
in 30 seconds or less.
One thing I want to mention,
you may have noticed that some
of the CSS properties have a
dash WEP key prefix, in Firefox
you may see the dash [? most ?]
prefix.
Those are experimental APIs.
People still figuring out
the right way to do it.
When they're finalized and
added to the spec the
prefix will be dropped.
And you know, some of the
others they did have a prefix
before being dropped.
How about more cool stuff?
How about 2D transforms?
With CSS 3 2D transforms
are native to the browser.
And on this slide we
show you 3 examples.
Rotate, scale and skew.
But let's see rotate in action.
So I'm going to hover
over this box.
And it'll rotate nicely and we
also have a bonus nice, smooth
transition. 2 lines of
code, very powerful API.
How about animations?
Do you guys remember the
notorious HTML blink tag?
00:30:21,84 --> 00:30:21,18
Yeah?
OK.
It was considered the most
obnoxious HTML tag ever
and some people even
call it simply evil.
So, can we do
better with CSS 3?
Yeah.
You see the code up there?
And ladies and gentlemen I
introduce to you CSS Pulse.
Now I hope I didn't open
Pandora's box, so please
don't over-abuse,
overuse this effect.
Too late.
I mentioned earlier the new
fonts available from Google
and the web font API.
Before that it was really
difficult to do one thing on
the web since the early days
on the web and that was
beautiful typography.
Nice typography on the web.
You had to do, you know, image.
You had to play with Flash.
Really headache.
Not anymore.
On this page we have an example
where we used I think 7 fonts
from the Google font directory
and if you get our humor we
wrote you a slightly
threatening note not to abuse
the pulse animation and we
did it like the in the
ransom notes, we used
newspaper clippings.
That's what you can do
with the @font face.
And finally, I want to mention
the flexible box model.
Another really powerful
addition to the CSS 3 spec.
With the flexible box model you
can do elastic and fluid
layouts that adapt to the font
size or the browser
window size.
Things you weren't able to do
before, so let me show you
a very simple demo here.
Very nicely, whenever the size
changes your layout will
nicely flow around it.
So this is exactly what was
needed to provide a simple
and easy solution to common
web design problems.
Form layout and vertical
centering just 2 of them.
How did we put all these
goodies to good use?
Ame will show us.
AME ROOMANN-KUMIK: So with
Chromabrush we definitely used
CSS a lot, but we really wanted
it to be kind of fairly subtle.
Even though Mihai really tried
to get me to put a blink tag
in there or a pulse tag.
I held out.
So basically it's
very lightweight.
We have a few rounded
corners here.
On the UI elements we have some
drop shadows on the toolbars.
That kind of thing.
We rendered the logo,
again using the new
font support in HTML5.
Did a few effects on that, but
mostly understated stuff.
We really wanted it to be
kind of like an elegant
desktop application.
But what I really think is like
the coolest part of the CSS 3,
kind of the new features that
we had available was the
ability to use box model.
The flexible box model spec.
So you can see here as I'm
resizing the browser window,
the things that are meant to
resize are resizing and
the things that are
not are constant.
And normally I've written
websites which calculate
the height of the window.
They listen to events.
There's usually some
lag behind that.
That kind of thing.
Well, all of the layout is
done entirely through CSS.
There's no JavaScript doing
the ratios or proportions
of this layout.
So the great thing about this
is that the browsers own
rendering engine decides
what goes where.
We just kind of tell it how we
want things to look, which is
kind of the point of CSS
in the first place.
You can see that even the
toolbar on the bottom, if I
make it too narrow, will
automatically reflow to fit
all the icons that
we have in there.
And the only reason it does
that is because those icons
are inline elements like
they're supposed to be.
So basically the browser
does it all for us.
We don't have to do any
complex calculations.
We still get all the advantage
of HTML and get to do some
pretty cool stuff with CSS.
So I'll just bring it back
to the presentation.
MIHAI FLORIN IONESCU:
Thank you, Ame.
That was awesome.
So we did some Chromabrush demo
ends, but not its development.
Chromabrush is open source.
You can find it on the web
at chromabrush.com or the
open source project at
chromabrush.googlecode.com.
We plan to work on it more and
add some more HTML goodies and
on this slide we have
a few examples.
We also invite the developer
community to contribute.
Have a look at it and let
us know what you think.
One thing that it's very easy
to do is to add on offline
experience for the user
through application cache.
With WebSocket we can add
the multiuser experience.
Imagine a whiteboard
application where remote users
from different parts of the
world collaborate on
the same drawing.
With geolocation we can go a
step further and add location
information for each one of
those users or drawings.
And of course
there's a lot more.
So that's why we
need your help.
Please go ahed, check out
the project and send
us your feedback.
Contribute to it.
With that said we are so
excited about what's coming up
that we allowed ourselves to
use the CSS Pulse or
the Pulse animation.
So we get one free pass and
with that please welcome
Chris Phenner and Mike
Park from Thumbplay.
CHRIS PHENNER: OK, so we're
going to take some of
things from this morning.
We're going to apply
them to music.
And I want to show you here,
with Mike's help, six things
that we're going to do that I
hope to show what the
attribute is, an actual
implementation of it.
Want to see it in action
and then [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
we can be clear about the
benefits we'll do that.
This is an adaptation
of Thumbplay Music.
A music service available
for $10 a month across
a lot of platforms.
Including soon those that
support HTML5 and we've
licensed over 8 million songs
and have had API across a lot
of platforms available
for some time.
And the first thing we'd like
to show you because it is
music is the audio tag.
Mike.
Made of HTML5 audio.
And we use that both in the
overlays within the feature and
then as the bottom embedded
player and we'll show you some
of the effects in
that in a second.
Now as you sort the songs in
this app by those that are
in this case, most popular.
We've pulled the
most popular API.
Mike's now pivoting using
the web database API.
There's a SQL-like database
running in here with all the
attributes related
to each track.
You'll see in a second.
So the metadata related to
this music including time.
You'll see then a preview path
to the 30 second stream.
An image path with its
imagery associated with it.
No trips to the server
are happening here.
As you saw from some of
the pivots Mike was doing
it happens really fast.
Now we're next you going to go
into one of the album releases.
LCD Soundsystem just yesterday
put out, "This is
Happening" and when the
list of songs in the songs tab
comes up you're going to see
Mike select the second one from
the album because he's all
psyched to hear it, but he
doesn't have time right now, so
he's going to drag it over to
the playlist menu on the left,
using-- you guessed
it-- drag and drop.
Now full disclosure, we did do
this in jQuery, because we're
waiting for the naive attribute
in HTML5 to bake a liitle bit,
but we're ready to do that.
And then I think you saw a
notification when the drag
and drop completed itself.
That is using the native
notifications API.
Mike's pop-uped a couple time.
The album cover art,
that's a CSS effect.
And then in CSS as we're
talking about it, Mike can
mouse over some of the embedded
player things that change
state and effects.
Also, up in search if Mike
wants to dive deeper in that
album and look for something
we're going to auto-fill what
the likely results are and then
as Mike tries to figure out
which one he actually wants to
do, you'll also see some
CSS effects there.
So we found that it puts the
presentation layer where it
belongs and away from the
code that handles real
logic, if you will.
I think that's everything.
That's Thumbplay music.
Oh, and there's one
more I always forget.
Mike has to go to a meeting in
the middle of this demo and he
doesn't have time and doesn't
want it to look like he was
wasting time, so he's now
closed in this case the
tab of the browser.
He's running to his meeting,
so it didn't look like he
was frittering around.
And now he's come back, but was
really psyched to get back to
where he left off with this
playlist and you may have
guessed it already.
We're about to see local
storage with the auto log-in.
We'll see a second of the
main page, but wait for it
and back where we were.
So that's all 6 attributes.
Thanks for letting a
non-developer walk
you through them.
And if you want it
I'll learn more.
I'd say the note to send to is
partners@thumbplay.com for
more, but thank you very much
for your time and attention.
MIHAI FLORIN IONESCU: Awesome.
During the keynote you got a
glimpse at the new HTML5
enabled TweetDeck and now I'd
like to invite Iain Dodsworth,
CEO and Founder of TweetDeck,
my favorite tweeting
app to show us more.
Thank you Iain.
IAIN DODSWORTH: Thank you.
OK, so I'm Iain Dodsworth.
CEO and Founder of TweetDeck.
At it's most simplest TweetDeck
is an application, sort of
famously if you like
on the desktop.
We've got it on the iPad
and also on the iPhone.
And Android coming very soon.
And it's designed to take quite
a lot of social network
information and make it
a lot more manageable.
That's at its most simplistic.
At its kind of normal run rate
it's a huge desktop application
that's very complicated and
very powerful and very black
and obviously I love it and
that's why I built
it like that.
So this is our HTML5 TweetDeck
and this is a little bit of a
departure for us because
everything else has
been a native app.
We obviously get most
of our usage from the
desktop at the moment.
So I think the main points on
this, obviously we can see
that we can scroll very
smoothly up and down.
We can go left and right.
Let's add a new column
in just like this.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
It's very quick.
The actual system resources
this takes is very low as well.
This is really at the moment
only using Twitter and Buzz.
We don't actually have a Buzz
integration at the moment, but
we have Buzz integrated in this
and we'll be working on this
over the next few weeks to put
Facebook in and to put all the
other social networks that are
kind of required
of a TweetDeck.
So it won't be very long before
we will get a fully featured
HTML5 version of a TweetDeck.
Which to be fair, we didn't
even know was possible
when we started.
So as it stands at the moment
this is an internal piece of
research, which obviously we're
incredibly happy to show today
and obviously our plan
is to put it out.
But I think the point that's
worth making here is that as a
traditional desktop company, if
you like, we really wanted to
prove that you could actually
do a TweetDeck in a web browser
and there was absolutely no way
we were going to do a
dumbed down, light version
of TweetDeck at all.
So it was either fully featured
or it's never going to
appear in a browser.
So you can see the we're kind
of getting there and I think
that's probably the right
approach in this instance.
So just some of the things you
can see, sort of on display.
So obviously we do have audio
alerts in the back, which at
the moment is kind
of not showing.
But the other element of this
is obviously with a full sort
of audio implementation we can
also build in a media player
into this so that we could
play everything inline.
You don't have to go
off to another page in
order to play audio.
We have notifications.
Desktop notifications in here
and that's been one of the main
reasons why we haven't actually
built a web version as well is
obviously we want notifications
and TweetDeck is not sort of
at the front all the time.
It's kind of sitting in the
background, churning away, so
notifications a huge part of
the sort of functionality.
Drag and drop of columns.
Little bit slow there.
The drag and drop of columns.
I mean, obviously the next
thing we'll do after that is
the dragging and dropping
of actual users as well.
So this is a very nice way of
creating lists and that kind of
thing where you have to use a
specific or Tweet specific
actions will now be able to do
the whole thing through drag
and drop inside a browser.
And of course there's offline
storage included so that
obviously if you just turn it
off and you come back it's
exactly where it was.
You won't use your place in a
column, especially if it's
kind of quite a long column.
And then kind of the final
thing on this is that we have a
CSS 3 layer on top as well, so
that we can get some fairly
nice animations in here.
So it's rather early days,
but it hasn't taken a huge
amount of time to get
to this point either.
It's kind of only been about
a month to get to this.
And I think to be fair you
will see a TweetDeck released
in the browser soon.
We've just got to prove that we
can get it all in, but this is
a fantastic start, so
thanks very much.
MIHAI FLORIN IONESCU: Amazing.
You know, absolutely
mind-blowing what you
can do with HTML5.
So it's time to wrap up.
Before we do that I want to
go over some key-takeaways
from this talk.
First, over the past year
we have seen a wave of
new HTML5 technologies
all gaining momentum.
And we expect the
trend to continue.
Second, browser innovation
is accelerating.
We are seeing that not only
with Google Chrome, but with
other browsers as well and it's
really great to see faster
JavaScript engines and more
powerful and better
developer tools.
Third, as we have seen from our
demos and examples, web
applications are getting closer
and closer to parity with
desktop applications.
We're close, we're getting
there and now with Google apps
store, web store launch you can
also monetize your
web applications.
And finally, we couldn't have
done any of these without the
involvement and support from
the developer community.
So please stay involved and
help us move the web forward.
Thank you.
We're starting our
Q&A session.
There's also a link as we
promised to developer
resources, it's a page where
we're going to keep adding
more and more resources
as we see fit.
And if you have a question
that's not yet in the moderator
please use the microphones
on both sides of the aisle.
AME ROOMANN-KUMIK: So I guess
we'll just start off with the
moderator question, what 3
HTML5 features can I implement
on my site quickly that
will benefit my users most?
Nice.
Well, what type of
site do you have?
Something I actually really
liked about the keynote was
Sports Illustrated talking
about you know, beautiful fonts
make readability a lot better.
And so if you can use fonts.
Like I honestly think that nice
layouts, getting kind of
creative, making the web like
more engaging for people
is very interesting.
In terms of a performance
benefit, obviously switching to
CSS, not using images as often.
Especially doing things like if
you're willing to sacrifice
rounded corners for everyone,
so that you can stop serving a
ton of rounded corner images
for example, I'd say switch to
that right away because it
will save you bandwidth.
Rendering time
will be improved.
That kind of thing.
You can also use new markup in
HTML5 for accessibility, which
is obviously extremely
important for users who might
rely on that and have browsers
that really need content to be
marked up correctly and in a
clean, kind of nice format.
So I think those are
pretty good features.
I don't know if you
have your own.
MIHAI FLORIN IONESCU: Let's
go quickly to some more
questions and then
we're going to be here.
If we didn't answer a question,
come talk to us or outside.
So when we see an ID for
writing HTML5 applications?
That pretty much
makes things easier.
During the keynote we just saw
a demonstration of Dreamweaver.
I'm sure others
are in the works.
With the momentum that I just
mentioned, behind the HTML5
applications, IDs--
Just a matter of time
before they appear.
Let's take a question
from the microphone.
AUDIENCE: From what we've seen
today of notifications it looks
like a very powerful tool with
a lot of uses, but what's being
done to prevent it from being
used by say, invasive
advertisers or
malicious software?
MIHAI FLORIN IONESCU: So you've
noticed both in the slides and
when Ame demonstrated our paint
applications you have to give
access to the notification API.
When the slide first appeared
you didn't have an access.
You specifically had to click
on the allow access for this
website to display
notification.
Once you do that it means
you trust the site and if
they annoy you you can
take out that right.
AME ROOMANN-KUMIK:
Additionally, notifications
have the option to disable
for the serving domain.
At least in Chrome and we're
hoping that other browser
implement some more features
so that the user is
in control of it.
AUDIENCE: Excellent.
Thank you.
AME ROOMANN-KUMIK:
Good question.
Thanks.
MIHAI FLORIN IONESCU:
Next question.
AUDIENCE: Can you say
anything about solutions
for specialized typography?
For example, in the math
community we use LaTeX a lot or
for musicians, music notation
and that sort of thing
within the browser?
MIHAI FLORIN IONESCU: We're
not specialists in that.
There is a talk about the web
fonts I believe later today.
AME ROOMANN-KUMIK: I'm not
sure about that time.
I have seen people do stuff
interesting in canvas.
Like I saw an implementation
in canvas of the
00:50:24,358 --> 00:50:24,078
LaTeX layout engine.
So if you know the CSS kind
of layout if you have full
justification isn't quite
as nice as the LaTeX one.
So someone actually wrote it in
canvas so they're rendering the
fonts in canvas and
doing it that way.
It's interesting.
I think obviously the spec
could probably include
additional text rendering
modes, but the progress we've
made so far is very good.
MIHAI FLORIN IONESCU: So for
those of you who don't know
there is an HTML5 group that
we all in the Chrome team
respond to questions.
So if we don't answer anything
here go and post your question
there and it will
get an answer.
We have more people that know
a lot more stuff then just
the two of us can answer.
00:51:08,054 --> 00:51:08,042
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
fast question, are you going to
post your HTML5 presentations
somewhere [INAUDIBLE]?
AME ROOMANN-KUMIK: So the
question was, are we
going to post it online?
Obviously yes, we will.
So the presentation is being
recorded and will be on YouTube
shortly and as soon as we just
basically just push it out to
an URL somewhere we'll make
sure that it's attached
to all the IO content.
So you'll have access.
I also kind of want to
open source it so you can
actually pick it apart
and do stuff with it.
MIHAI FLORIN IONESCU: Reuse
it, spread the word.
HTML5 is cool.
AME ROOMANN-KUMIK: Let's
take one more from the--
MIHAI FLORIN IONESCU: One
more from the microphone.
AUDIENCE: For this notification
model there was obviously like
a permission system where the
app can request permissions
from the user, is that limited
to domain or does is persist?
Is there any extra
functionality there?
Or is it simply, every single
time they load the app they
have to give permission again?
AME ROOMANN-KUMIK:
That's a good question.
The question, so does
the notification
permission persist?
It does persist.
It's per domain.
You can think of it kind of
like in the same model as I
guess, what would
be a good way?
Kind of like an AJAX thing
where it's all kind of scoped
through the same domain
or like a cookie thing.
And you know, the user can
revoke it at any time.
The browser should have
its own UI for that
kind of thing as well.
For the most part you'll have
to say yes once and as long as
you don't want to disable
it it'll stay on.
Now an interesting part of the
apps store or sorry the web
store, the Chome web store is
that Chrome web apps can
actually declare that they want
this permission up front, so
when the user installs it
they'll preemptively
agree to it.
And then the app will be able
to send notifications without
that bar and Chrome extensions
can do that as well,
which is pretty cool.
I'm not sure if this is kind of
like a meta question or if it's
just really a legitimate bug.
MIHAI FLORIN IONESCU:
Someone is testing us.
AME ROOMANN-KUMIK: Yeah, HTML--
I'm not good at grokking the
solve HTML4 issues, bring new
concepts to web, extend mobile
platforms, just a
regular update.
I'm not really sure.
Sorry.
MIHAI FLORIN IONESCU: We are
geeks, but we can't read.
AME ROOMANN-KUMIK: HTML verus
apps, what are your thoughts?
I don't think it
needs to be versus.
MIHAI FLORIN IONESCU:
HTML5 apps are apps.
That's what we just
showed you today and
all our invited guests.
AME ROOMANN-KUMIK: And I used
Photoshop and I'll use
Chromabrush when I want
something lightweight.
Hopefully the line will blur
even more as we go ahead.
Will HTML5 file API
work on mobile?
That's really up to
mobile I guess.
If mobile implements it, which
actually brings an interesting
point that mobile browsers are
actually the ones that are
implementing a lot of these
features the quickest.
Mostly because a lot of them
are WebKit based and WebKit
adopts a lot of these
features rather quickly.
They're useful for mobile.
Things like offline mode is
really essential for web, for
mobile web to work, so I'm
assuming that it will work on
mobile at some point, but
it's just not there yet.
MIHAI FLORIN IONESCU: Mobile
drives the development
of some HTML5 features.
For example, application
cache it's very useful
on mobile phone.
You have offline access to
your apps when you don't
have a good connection.
AME ROOMANN-KUMIK: Why
don't we take a person.
AUDIENCE: How did the
Chromabrush, how was it
able to save images to a
files from that canvas?
AME ROOMANN-KUMIK: So the
question, how does Chromabrush
saves images to a
file from the canvas?
Well, it doesn't right
now, which is like
the easiest answer.
But as soon as I get back to
work I'm assuming that I'll
probably just bounce it off
the server and have the user
download it using the native
browser kind of thing.
I have to look into drag and
drop out of the browser,
which you could do as well.
But the thing is that for that
you basically need to have the
user drag an image,
not a canvas.
So canvas has a nice API that
you can get in like a raw data
string that's a PNG file.
So you can do things with that.
You can store it online.
Upload it to web service,
you can prompt the user
to save it somewhere.
Eventually we could do the file
API, but again, that wouldn't
be on the file system it
would be kind of in the
apps own file space.
MIHAI FLORIN IONESCU: That is
an excellent question and shows
us that we still have this much
to go to bridge the gap with
desktop applications and that's
why you know, all this stuff,
all those questions, all these
problems are really great
to push forward the
development of HTML5.
And you know, new APIs like
file APIs and other things
the community is working
on will solve this.
AME ROOMANN-KUMIK: Also
consider, how would use save
a file from a browser?
A browser can save files, but
has its own mechanism for that.
It's not quite the
same as the desktop.
Good point.
AUDIENCE: So I worked at Real
Networks about 10 years ago and
we were working on a language
called Smile, I don't know if
you're familiar with that.
But it allows you to control
when media was downloaded and
does HTML5 have anything like
that where you can actually
control, load this video,
preload this video, schedule
something else coming in 10
seconds later because I'm
assuming with modern browsers
and bandwidth it's not a
problem, but on mobile phones
it probably will be an issue
where you're going to need to
have some access to that?
AME ROOMANN-KUMIK: Yes.
So I mean, there are techniques
that you can use to preload.
The HTML5 video tag has its own
kind of DOM states you can
detect whether something's
loaded or not and
ready to play.
It's as simple as putting a
video element in the page and
the browser will get it and
when it's ready you can
say, do something.
You can also use JavaScript to
script elements dynamically,
insert them into the page.
Is that what you were--
AUDIENCE: There's actually
going to be some sort of event
spawned when it's ready to play
or you'll be able to say I've
got this much available
in the cache?
You actually have
access to that?
AME ROOMANN-KUMIK: Yeah, that's
in the video tag, so you
can actually determine.
You get an event for when you
have enough to play and the
buffering would take you
to the end assuming that
the rate stays the same.
You also get an event when
the movie is buffered.
00:57:38,478 --> 00:57:38,458
And you can play it.
MIHAI FLORIN IONESCU: Let's
take one more question
from the moderator.
Is the Chrome Team planning
on implementing HTML5
form input widgets soon?
So if you guys go to the
developer resources you will
find there's a link which says
web platform status and we try
to keep that up to date.
It tells you for each one of
the HTML5 APIs we're working
on where are we at with
the implementation.
Of course you can also look
at the Chromium discussion
list and all that stuff.
So this is in the works.
You know, there are actually
examples out there that
show different cases
of different examples.
And once that makes its way
into a more stable release
or better release we'll
have a lot of examples.
They're coming.
AME ROOMANN-KUMIK: So the
sliders in the presentation
were actually forum
input fields also.
We didn't do anything special
for the draggable sliders.
Chrome is taking care
of that for us.
WebKit actually I think.
It's actually kind of funny
because the sliders look
native to each platform.
That kind of thing.
And you know, we don't have
support for every single input,
but we're getting there and
they're pretty cool to play
with, so worth checking out.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
MIHAI FLORIN IONESCU:
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: But I'm curious about
the multimedia streaming,
everything so far has been
a progressive download
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
AME ROOMANN-KUMIK: The question
is about, what about HTML5
support for streaming?
As far as I know, I
don't know actually.
00:59:12,446 --> 00:59:12,422
I haven't kept up with that.
MIHAI FLORIN IONESCU:
Some play streaming.
AME ROOMANN-KUMIK:
So there you go.
Awesome.
I think we have one more.
AUDIENCE: I'll give you
an unpopular question.
Is it possible to provide
some sort of DRM protection
for video in HTML5?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
AME ROOMANN-KUMIK:
I don't know.
MIHAI FLORIN IONESCU: The
question was, is it possible
to write a DRM protection
in HTML5 for video?
AME ROOMANN-KUMIK: I mean, I
would tell you that there are
probably people here who would
say it's impossible to write
a DRM system in general.
AUDIENCE: I know
it's unpopular.
I was thinking in the
previous app example.
AME ROOMANN-KUMIK:
I agree with you.
It's a desire that
some people have.
As far as I know I don't
have an answer for you
01:00:03,808 --> 01:00:03,792
regarding that yet.
So sorry.
MIHAI FLORIN
IONESCU: Thank you.
We have a few seconds left.
One more question.
Regarding local storage from
users perspective, how if
possible could one view-delete
such application data?
So there is an API to access,
you know, add, remove
local storage.
We are working on various specs
and prototypes to give the user
more power to see what's in the
local database and local cache.
Delete stuff, revoke
permissions.
You saw in the thumbnail demo
how they showed you what's
in the local database.
So something along those
lines is in the works.
AUDIENCE: Just to add onto to
that the Chrome developer
tools [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
MIHAI FLORIN
IONESCU: Thank you.
So the gentlemen over
there mentioned, use the
01:00:55,64 --> 01:00:55,48
Chrome developer tools.
They give you great insight
of what is in your local
storage and local databases.
Thank you sir.
With that we'll
have to wrap up.
We're overtime.
We're going to be around,
come talk with us.
Thank you.